hey welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Erik Bosse I'm marina mess that's right
hey happy holidays everyone this is a
big question Phillips not here because
Cooper spent from going around the world
and stuffing the stockings with millions
of children with muscle supplements we
all deserve a good rest and tiny
t-shirts here now we're gonna answer
your big question because you know the
rise of Skywalker's behind us and now
all we're left with is a Mandalorian
final episode which might be out now by
the time you're watching it we haven't
seen it yet so now we're just gonna
decide to spend our Star Wars efforts on
answering the [ __ ] out of every question
you have about baby Odin yep starting
with the most important question of all
Erik how does baby Yoda age
that's a great question marina and you
know it actually is a lot of biological
science behind it people have researched
it I've compiled it all into my stack of
cards here's the thing George Lucas has
never defined the baby Otis species it
may be defined in the final episode of
the Mandalorian people we don't know but
he never intended to define the speak he
always wanted it to be a mystery the one
character in Star Wars who doesn't have
a training card that tells you
everything about him yeah is Yoda so we
don't know if Yoda is a mammal or a
reptile he's green as many reptiles are
but he does have hair oh so we don't
know if he was just dating in an egg or
placental sac like the mammals are or in
a marsupial pouch and just his ears are
sticking yeah just the ears and that's
how you know but he's sleeping don't
wake him you know when you get back to
how the yoda species was designed yeah
in the Empire Strikes Back is he was
based off of Albert Einstein's face and
the puppeteers face to kind of Merchant
together but the species seems to be
based on the tortoise right he's old
tortoises aged very slowly yeah they are
green or just like they were green in
the Fez brown but like when we draw them
with Crayola colors we use the green one
they surprise that science that science
so here's we know about baby Yoda he or
she at whatever is 50 years old behaves
like a toddler though
you've gotta waddles around watts toys
what's toys not a toy he coos he cries
he sleeps a lot he does not talk he puts
frogs in his mouth a lot and scientists
say that human babies explore the worlds
orally for a period they put everything
in their mouth yeah right and those are
usually from the ages of 6 months to 18
months we're kind of clocking baby Yoda
at around a one-year-old yeah but he
walks to he walks and you know babies
can walk around ages 12 months I didn't
walk till I was five yeah some of us
still can't the active speech actually
doesn't necessarily tell us much because
it could just be a result of lack of
exposure we learn language from right
parents and from other adult figures
talking around us from television so we
don't know what kind of contact
baby Yoda has had with other species the
other Yoda that we know speaks in that
inverted sentence structure that could
have been the result of how his brain
functions differently or from people who
read things okay yeah in speaking of
that baby Yoda actually has the profound
levels of empathy of course you know
like maybe I oughta consents when people
are hurt or need is help normal babies
don't do that they're selfish little
jerks and they never use the force hole
your earrings punch your boobs ya know
cause more pain if anything baby baby is
a little demon human life expectancy as
we know is around 72 to 90 years some
people say it's around 80 to 120 years
hundred twenty so mapping that to Yoda
Yoda died when he was nine hundred years
old yes his 900th birthday and Return of
the Jedi
so assuming exact correlation mapping
one on to the other baby Otis should be
at the developmental stage of the human
equivalent of five years old at 50 years
would equal five years here's more
things we know about baby Otis age and
the mandalorian pilot IG 11 the assassin
droid says that species age differently
which is something to keep in mind and
that's not just in the Star Wars
universe that's an RT or universe - and
doesn't mean we just yeah subspecies age
more slowly or live longer lifespans and
others it means we hit sexual maturity
at different
stages of our lifetimes some of us still
aren't interested it's totally fine just
to give some examples the cicada the
cicada stays into cocoon or a larval
stage underground for 17 years crazy and
then blossoms out and then stays an
adult for a very short period of time
that's its whole lifecycle they say dogs
right age seven times faster that's not
exact right so like a two-year-old dog
it's not a fourteen-year-old humorous
more like a 20 year old human and then
you know dogs at very old ages what
would normally be like an 80 year old
human can still be very spry and active
and and have lots and lots of sex I was
looking up some crazy numbers on animals
around the world
tortoises as we mentioned before can
live over a hundred years old up to 250
years old Oh is right oh my god they
reached their sexual maturity at 30
years old so that's about somewhere
between 12 and 30% of their lifespan the
Greenland shark listen to this one can
live for roughly 270 to 400 years oh
because it's cold water is that what it
is you just put anything in cold water
live 200 years old the Greenland shark
doesn't reach its sexual maturity until
150 years old so it lives 150 years old
doing nothing never getting a boner
yeah and then one day 150 its birthday
so at a hundred years that's about 28 to
55 percent about halfway through their
life a lot of them there's only when
they reach sexual maturity humans of
course we live somewhere around 100
years maybe we reach our sexual maturity
at age 13 so about 13% of our life span
lobsters fun fact are often considered
biologically immortal because their
cells do not replicate the ways ours do
they molt and then they basically revert
back to that pre adult stage and they
continue that so my god Wow forever and
ever and ever they can live up to 100
years if undisturbed usually what
they'll do is they'll either die out
from exhaustion while they try to molt
the last time or because they're so
delicious something eats them they can
outlive all of us if we don't eat them
which is why it's important that we eat
these what is this all about
well this is all to say the baby Yoda
aging is not directly proportional to
human aging right he is a baby now at
age 50 but like at age 75 he could
rapidly go through his species version
of puberty and then get really a no lien
for a couple years and then hit what's
interesting I looked this up according
to Yoda's canonical the real Yoda's
canonical history he became a Jedi
Master at age 100 so wait what yes at
one point he said I had been training
Jedi for 800 years he's nine hundred
years old when he dies so he must have
been wise enough verbal enough and
literate enough to be a Jedi Master at
age 100 so what happens between fifty
and a hundred in the other species that
must be around the time they hit their
puberty and then rapidly age up to them
adults which would be around eight or
nine percent of their lifetime so
basically the yoda species age is slowly
slowly slowly slowly aged 100 and then
lives a hundred years as an as a grandpa
yeah that's all of the species think of
it we're human and we age that way it
would be like a young boy acting like a
baby until he's five years old and then
between ages of five and ten transforms
into a grandpa ten year old grandpa and
then stays with grandpa for 80 years and
then dies what a life yeah and it's
interesting how like you've seen in the
prequels they went back and tried to
make a younger version of Yoda to show
what like a younger version would look
like and that would only be like 30
years before we saw him in Return of the
Jedi
yeah George Lucas thought it looked
weird which it did because the lights
they used in made his skin look a darker
shade of green than it really is they
tried to add more hair to him his eyes
weren't the right size what they didn't
attack of the clones is they made a CGI
version that was more closely based on
the Empire Strikes Back version and
that's a version that they used from
there forward and they even went back to
Phantom Menace and CGI that Yoda on top
of the puppet Yoda that they use for
Phantom Menace oh wow so any last Jedi
it's the puppet it's like the actual
puppet and last Jedi it's the puppet but
it's like a puppet based on the Empire
Strikes Back I mean it's not literal
like it is a puppet so that that should
be
a good explanation it's that yeah that's
so interesting good a great answer to a
big question old question well we're
gonna get to some more bite-sized
questions after a special message from a
sponsor that probably is just me talking
about hey guys Eric here just a reminder
that new rock stars is offering
exclusive rewards to our patrons in the
form of bonus videos each month you can
get exclusive access along with lots of
other behind-the-scenes content and just
a general good feeling of helping this
channel grow have becoming an official
patron of new rock stars Digital Studios
just go to patreon.com/scishow ours
again that's patreon.com/lenguin
welcome back to the big question we're
now going to move on to some bite-sized
questions that marinas gonna be ready
marina yeah baby questions okay first
baby question comes from add bacon ate
him what is Thanos his sword made out of
good question okay so if we think back
to endgame
Thanos actually breaks Captain America
is vibranium shield yes with his sword
and vibranium is supposed to be the most
powerful or strongest metal on earth
yeah but but but thanassis sword is not
from Earth oh that's right okay there's
no earthly nor a big and purple except
Philip it has been he's really cold yeah
thanassis sword is actually made from
Aroo he went to native lear right to
have each we make it for him yeah it's
what Thor's Hammer's are made out of
yeah so it's kind of this like
otherworldly metal that they have we
don't have access yeah so that's how we
kind of get our work around and we see
you know his his expression when it
breaks he's like oh oh yeah so if you
were to sharpen like theoretically
Stormbreaker could wedge into cap shield
but why would they ever fight their best
buds yeah okay moving on to our next
bite-sized lucas manga lon asks if there
are humans and star wars then is there
an earth it's possible but
unlikely so we know that George Lucas
you know all the Star Wars movie start
with long time ago galaxy far far away
and he actually intended these movies to
be viewed by a future alien species
which is totally normal and they're
basing a religion based on the Wills
journals Oh Luke Starkiller and then
journals of the Wills original script
title right and he wanted them to like
do base their religion on like the
series of events so this isn't based on
like Star Trek is like Earth you know
Battlestar Galactica is earth it's just
science fiction versions of our planet
that was Star Wars this fantasy
completely different things so I mean
fantastically speaking maybe there's
like some alternate universe where earth
exists but I think it's not likely God
based on science no but you know well
it's the idea of it is a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away it's not to
earthly an audience the intended
audience are this future alien race or
at least that was George Lucas's
original idea for it yeah okay okay
makes sense so no sorry it's not they're
just happy to look like us and be
bipedal in the most case and their
numbers kind of look like Arabic numbers
anyway mm-hmm Rob Chalmers at Bert
Chalmers asks does Morgan Stark carry
extremists or extremists as extremists
passed down genetically I'm gonna say no
because Pepper Potts is genetically
normal until the events of Iron Man 3
something it you know is invades her
body takes her over but it comes right
back out of her again and unless it's
sort of like altered in her DNA which is
not present in any of the story lines
then like it just goes right back out of
her and I don't see any reason why that
would affect her uterus or her DNA or
anything like that so she just goes on
to have a normal kid normal in a normal
way you know I mean maybe they'll change
it in the future but I don't see any
biological reason why that would happen
it's in its out like she goes back to
being totally honest it seems like after
Ironman through the MCU is kind of moved
on from extremists and it doesn't really
have any bearing on pepper in the future
she probably would have used it in that
final battle she wouldn't need that
exactly if she still had any remnants
she would have put it to you
yeah and they clearly like made a big
point of it's no longer in her system so
whatever it changes during DNA shouldn't
have been able to have been passed on
it's a whole Lamarck theory of evolution
what was it am i getting the name wrong
where it's like they showed that image
of the giraffe and like if the drafts
neck can get longer to eat the leaves
can he pass down a longer neck to his
offspring and know like physiological
changes you over in your lifetime are
not heritable traits technically every
time I speak this is actual science
technically every time a species
reproduces or anything reproduces at
least on earth mutations occur they
happen every single time and they are
completely random so that giraffe with
the long neck will upon reproducing have
random mutation in their offspring maybe
they'll get a longer neck they just as
easily might not because mutations are
random it's really the the draft that
had the genes for a longer neck when it
was born is just more fit to survive
right it's not like during his lifetime
he can work to make his neck longer pass
it on to its kid and if you're gonna say
like well things like STDs can be passed
on to kids or things like AIDS or like
addictions we passed by those are a
result of the mother and the child
sharing nutrients sherry in a blood
stream and that's how kids can be born
with with AIDS and things like diabetic
behaviors I believe the same way you're
just genetically predisposed but it
takes social and genetic activation to
actually have a manifest it's my
understanding of the science and kids
who have like obesity at young ages it's
because they're like learning and
getting eating habits from their parents
there's a lot of that happening at young
ages but it's not like you get fat
during the course of your lifetime
you're not naturally predisposed to be
fat you do it your kids might be born
fat they're a giant baby big a doctor is
like that's a big one it takes a picture
of it fish photos yeah I bet the doctors
do that well thanks for asking those
bite size questions but now we're gonna
move on to our fan mail question yes
we're just a mailbag
it's not about the box it's a big
question box but you think you mailed it
to us at this address below some of
these people tweeted it had some patron
send us some questions we were grateful
to get but yeah send us anything you
want mail it to us we got appeal box
anything if it's a box it'll come out on
the show alright so let's see what we
got in here
great this episode Matthew Carlene from
patreon whatever our patrons there's so
much Matt asks would you rather live in
a world with superheroes or Pokemon ooh
I choose superheroes because then I can
be one of them but what if you aren't
what if you're just fine then I'm still
say superheroes because Pokemon I feel
like our little toddlers and they would
just get in your way and be so annoying
but they're little so you can't like
reprimand them they're like little
babies who like punch your boob and pull
your face right yeah or they're just
like animals and like you can't like and
I hate about a dog on an airplane yeah
you're not gonna complain about a
Snorlax on a plane which is what I feel
about with Pokemon because I feel like I
would rather live in a Pokemon universe
yeah why absolutely because superheroes
would probably look like something like
the boys on Amazon they'd be like evil
and they'd be criminals and like we see
what happens in the MCU the birth of
superheroes in the universe just leads
to more challenges and bigger threats
coming up to challenge I don't want to
be blipped but I'd rather live with
Pokemon which is just like everyone gets
like a cool badass slash friend yeah
it's kind of like His Dark Materials
where everyone gets like an animal
spirit guide but instead their Pokemon
like I'd rather live within the universe
of detective Pikachu then I am see you
absolutely that seems way more fun agree
to disagree but I already said my answer
I already said mine this question is
from Travis also from patreon take this
Travis you're the best Thank You Travis
what is a time that gave you stage
rights can be from your childhood or can
be from two weeks stage right not
including right now we do have a huge
studio audience and they're very quiet
it's if we had a studio out it's this
whole time and they all of them are just
been silent yeah they've been stoic we
it's because Tommy's not here time he's
a strong guy he gets mad he throws candy
at oh yeah
stage fright I don't really get stage
fright
because we've done a bunch of improv
comedy shows and at that point you get
in front of a crowd I'm gonna say when
we did the comic-con panel because it
was my very first comic-con panel ever
and although I worked very hard to have
a lot of knowledge about this stuff that
I talked about I'm mostly up like my
expertise is Star Trek horror Buffy
like x-files like not this particular
genre so I was a little bit like oh I'm
gonna get up on that panel and people
are gonna ask us questions unless they
know all the members of the sinister six
for me every version of the commies yeah
and then you guys were just gonna be
like do it marina yes I'm putting you on
the spot and then I would work you did
great though I did okay yeah I'm working
really hard to deepen my knowledge not
that I have none but it's it's not
comparable to you guys as yet so that
was the time when I was like oh my
wonderful that's the thing about like as
much of an expert as you can claim to be
in comic books there's always someone
who knows more so like no one is the
true expert except Stanley and he's know
there was a mob well some of the taping
scenarios like if we're in front of
cameras the quieter the room those
scarier it is for me so I've gone
another four camera testing auditions
for this and I mean the first audition I
different new rockstars back in 2015 I
didn't get the job initially I was super
nervous it's just like Philip in the
room yeah I did not get the job you can
find the video somewhere here what's
wrong there it is look at that awkward
dope you know we got it was Drew
Coolidge got that job did a great job at
the rosters they moved on to bigger and
better things
yeah he's much happier I'm sure no I'm
doing this job
second fiddle oh here's a fun story this
is true stage fright and college Philip
and I did a lot of like improv and
sketch together and there was one sketch
I can't remember why we did this bit but
I was dressed as a peanut rapping about
Jimmy Carter because Jimmy Carter was a
peanut farmer and we did this yeah the
whole bit was I do rap new parody lyrics
on top of Run DMC's tricky oh that's
great yes Jimmy so I was like let's talk
about Jimmy Carter Jimmy Carter Jimmy
Carter Jimmy
it's Jimmy Jimmy man
like these peanuts are real tasty I was
wearing like these big white gloves big
white shoes I was it was kind of like
the Justin Timberlake yeah I didn't get
the words right there was I just didn't
have time to memorize the words so and
this is supposed to be like our big
closer a show like I was a big moment
like whoa this guy Brad and I had to do
that thing where you vamp and then I
have amped so many times the song ran
out so at the end I was just like trying
to get through these lyrics a cappella
could see me shaking there's video of it
somewhere I'm like my big white hands
are quivering yeah I should just walk
off the stage I didn't I was like I have
to get these I have to say oh I think
most frightened I've ever been on stage
and I had been doing shows for like two
years at that point
memories content is terrified I was more
afraid of a scripted content than
unscripted content yeah we're
improvisers not yeah don't sketch since
then I've gotten better at it but that's
not good I am an improviser
let's get back to a script okay Donnie
at Third Ward TX asks what has been the
craziest fan experience you guys have
ever had since becoming celebrities
people throwing themselves at you
autograph somebody parts not the parts
you want fan weird fan arts dish guys
dish
well celebrities is an extremely strong
yeah I mean you're definitely a hundred
percent thousand percent more well-known
than I am give it a give it a couple
months we do get recognized some time to
tell you I've literally never been
recognized okay I have been a few times
I'm happy yeah they're always so nice
the people who like come up to me in
restaurants or at the movie theater or
anywhere I am are always like the
sweetest sweetest people and I think
it's because like the kind of content we
do and the kind of people who seek out
this content it's all appreciative and
they just want to like things as opposed
to other like nerd channels they'll be
cynical or dismissive so like the people
who end up saying coming up to us are
always those kind of sweet nice people
so I like meeting fans and viewers and
subscribers in the street there was
one guy when I see you saw spider-man
far from home super nice but I was
sitting on the aisle in the movie
theater Eddie comes up to me and he goes
I could recognize and I was like what
were we gonna slip that's worth even in
the dark but he was really nice thanks
man I was like with my notepad like
trying to write down all the license
plate that was nice
there was one fan if you're trying to
get like the crazy ones when I we were
talking about this before we taped when
I we were doing Game of Thrones
breakdowns which was the first videos I
did for the channel in season six after
drew Coolidge retired after drew cool is
retired
there was a photo that I put on my
Instagram of in my dad's backyard in
Florida he has those faces that you
could put on trees and Crete people out
and I was like I was like a weirwood
tree so I took a selfie with my hand up
too and I like rolled my eyes back to
look like I was walking through the tree
someone sent me a Photoshop version of
this picture which the tree was just a
giant erect penis and so me like
pictures well we blurred it out here's
the thing though I'm pretty sure that
was Phillip who did it because Phillip
is an amazing Photoshop and no one has
the time to perfectly like pixelate
around my hand to make it look like
someone put a lot of crafts in this and
Phillip was one who shared it with me
and I thought I flagged and scrubbed it
from the internet but it keeps like
showing up in our discord either beast a
dip or sterling he has the original file
Phillip is trolling you yeah so what do
you say you're standing off stage right
here shaking his head he's yeah he's
denying it but I know that is so funny I
have a couple of marriage proposals in
my Instagram DMS ooh have you said yes
nope I never open any of them for my own
personal safety everyone seems really
sweet but you know I forget you live a
different life because of this stuff
than I do
it's nice for me I'm very small and can
be easily murdered so I don't answer
anybody so don't take it personally
laughs and also don't do it baby
there there
I know I'm not gonna if you're one of
the well-meaning dudes in it know that
from marinas protege you can't because
it's all coming in with all this other
really creepy yeah absolutely you can't
tell which it's just for my own safety
so you know it's nice know that I have
offers if I ever become really lonely at
the end of my life and I'm you know I'm
like we still have Instagram and I'm
gonna go back through and be like hey
buddy we're yet until then you know
don't take it first and I'll be
philipbeasley
this account every comment on the
internet it's just Phillip Molina these
are baby
that would be really funny if all of our
trolls are just Phillip we are all
Phillip as well all the studio audience
oh yeah yeah we are Phillip Phillip is
us I'm Phyllis puppet you're doing two
different people we're singing the same
song and that's really what life is all
about different but we're singing to the
same melody hey I think we've answered a
lot of cool we should all be very
grateful
alright Venera class has been marina
Mastro's it's been a crazy crazy year
but thanks for joining us here in
rockstars and be sure to send us your
questions hashtag a big question
subscribe to new rock stars and have fun
[Music]